one reason that Marvel superheroes have
endured for decades is because there's
such powerful metaphors
spider-man started out as a metaphor for
awkward adolescence the x-men and their
mutant pals are often stand-ins for
racism and other forms of intolerance
and of course Ironman it's just a
metal-clad midlife crisis with rocket
boots of repulsor Ray's instead of a
Porsche and a cover band and then
there's the Hulk who is a subtle and
many-faceted metaphor for getting
completely cheesed off and he's a good
one
as far as excuses for antisocial
behavior ago I was irradiated with
energy that transforms me into a
gigantic primal monster when I'm
provoked is a lot better than say jello
shots still I'm required by law to
wonder what would it be like if the
gamma radiation that infused dr. banners
mitochondrial DNA or whatever the
excuses this time around what if it
worked on an emotion other than anger
the inquisitive Hulk
hey dr. banner come look at this it's an
oblique but compelling clue
don't make me curious you wouldn't like
me when I'm curious it's okay just take
a look it's a broken-off heel from a
pair of stilettos but it's covered in
some sort of light blue powder really
how could it know what to get to bottom
of tantalizing mystery
oh god no get away from me I'll shoot
where you get off the dig World War one
Webley revolver would hook get more
curious Hulk gets stronger the
inconsolable Hulk so uh I was wondering
if you wanted to you know go to eat it
with me yeah I know a kind of romantic
place to stay oh I'm sorry Bruce I
really like you a lot but I think of you
as a friend
a really good friend oh of course
right Ament I'm and
two goats into hideous friends just tell
round oh I hurt your feelings didn't I
no Hulk like us Fred - Hulk actually
kind of seeing someone not seriously
just you know hook up thing Oh get lots
of play
really you never mentioned anyone well
see it Europe right now backpacking can
we get check hulka's per day the
indifferent Hulk Hey Bruce where do you
want to get dinner oh I don't care
oh god I don't care okay with anything
geez we can't go out with you like that
quick form a strong opinion Beauty
humans always what hope to feel strongly
about things which is okay with Hulk
either way okay uh we'll go to that new
vegan raw food restaurant I hear they're
sprouted flax seed and watercress salad
is great
no that overpriced hippie crap
Hulk rather Ito toenails Hulk Hulk Oh
get a fresh shirt Bruce we're headed to
the barbecue barn the insecure Hulk I'm
so weak and timid I wish I was hope
strong and powerful Hulk rage it was
self esteem
Hulk totally oh I'm not strong at all
I've got skinny arms and I could smash
anything Hulk is awesome Hulk is mousy
and feeble and tough and my dear nobody
will want to stand up to hogs massive
ego problem I should probably just get
some therapy and kick people in the face
you